dans une interview accordée le week-end
dernier au midi libre va il m'a la jav
baisse à redon expliquer comment
réagissait notamment mains baladeuses
des garçons elle a bien fait comprendre
qu'il fallait pas venir la chercher et
c'est une nouvelle sortie donc illustre
très bien le fort caractère et le franc
parler de cette nouvelle miss france qui
bien bien différente des autres
est-ce qu'on lem est ce qu'elle nous
énerve regardez on en parle après madame
h avaient tous la cherche
tu la trouves fin matière noire la
nouvelle miss france a plus de répartie
qu'un ténor du barreau signer la version
de la miss trop sage est trop lisse ça
c'était avant
avec vaima lama il ya plein de choses
qui vont changer on peut avoir les
salles et des miss france s'est entendu
dire que c'était un truc qui devait
ressembler à ça mais pour moi c'est ici
jamais dans la foule des admirateurs y
en un qui a un peu trop les mains
baladeuses
quand je sens qu'il ya une main qui
commence à descendre un peu trop bas
tout de suite je réagis je mets un coup
de coude
il m'arrive aussi d'écraser des pieds
maïga lamah faut pas la chercher on vous
l'avait dit laurent baffie le week-end
dernier a tenté de faire le malin
[Applaudissements]
pourtant elles sont toutes c'est dommage
que vous ne voyez comme maintenant
baffie qui aime tant distribuer les
claques s'est vite fait remettre à sa
place cette réforme qui fait des bandes
et à l'époque et depuis le temps qu'on
en rêvait attention vous allez finir au
coin tu vas te mettre à genoux
à part ça vaille malama explose aussi
les codes de la miss qu'elle prend un
malin plaisir à redéfinir sa veste une
personne tout à fait normal qui va faire
ses courses qui achète son papier
toilette parce que oui elle va aussi aux
toilettes et le summum c'est quand la
tahitienne célibataire envisage
justement de ne plus l'être si j'ai un
copain bas j'aimerais passer des moments
avec lui et pas forcément avoir à les
dévoiler ou une copine ce que je pouvais
mais les filles s'il y en a pas mal qui
sont pas mal du tout une miss france
sans filtre top ou pas top pour
connecter les différentes capitales
heures à l'anr l énarque certains y en a
d'autres qui l'adorent en plus qu'un
voilà on aime ou on n'aime pas le laisse
pas indifférent
elle reste qu'elle en fait trop ou
est-ce qu'en revanche elle n'en fait pas
assez ou est ce qu'elle est plutôt
normal c'est assez étonnant mais vous
rachel qui avait été miss et encore pour
moment vous l'êtes encore tellement vous
êtes zèle pour vol en fait trop pourquoi
elle vous énerve
non pas du tout s'est pas calmée nerveux
c'est juste que moi j'ai été un peu à
l'ancienne école ouais donc on avait une
parole à moi j'étais super impressionné
par par geneviève etc
j'osais pas me la ramener comme ça même
si des fois au fond j'avais envie de
faire une petite blagounette tout cas
mais je je je vous dernière et où ça
vous agace
je peux pas dire que ça m'agace après
moi j'aimerais qu'elle montre un peu
plus peut-être de parce que j'ai
l'impression que toutes ces sorties sont
basses du buzz
ben oui en fait qu'elle cherche à ce que
faire du buzz à faire du à faire du buzz
mais après voilà c'est sympa c'est dans
l'air du temps mais malgré tout donc
vous vous arrêtez là mossawa demain télé
loisirs rachel de grains je déteste la
nouvelle miss elle cherche à faire du
buzz on l'a fait dans la boîte
elle était mais ce trop tard tu te
ramasses était trop tard en revanche qui
à mon avis il aime bien physiquement la
troupe formidable pourquoi mais c'est
top
et elle a raison parce que son but c'est
pas d'être miss france 2010 9 elle l'est
déjà ce qu'elle veut c'est être une
femme 2020 2021 2022
et pour pouvoir avoir un futur faut
forcément qu'elle crée le buzz parce que
la foire aux asperges en 508 avec la
foire au boudin à la queue leu leu et
tous ces trucs là à moi j'ai fait la
quinzaine du reblochon faire une fois la
quinzaine groupe auchan elle va devoir
faire 55 fois des trucs capsauto thomas
mois ce qui est peu jean-claude non ce
qui m'agace un peu michel c'est quand
elle dit par exemple j'étais étonné je
ne m'attendais pas ce qu'il disait
antenne quelque chose qui signifie en
quelque sorte dont elle parle de
l'émission
voilà miss france utiliser son image
pour vous branlée et faire des enfants
c'est vraiment pas chouette d'abord
c'est un peu vulgaire ce qu'elle dit et
puis ensuite par dont dix ont un peu la
vérité c'est un concours de beauté ans
et de gauche et c'est pas bon
v pay alors derrière pour pas arrivé et
commencer à dire et mon intelligence et
bons d'achat tu as été élu pour ta
beauté
non mais c'est pas une possible annonce
alors alors luxe oui mais non parce que
laurent ruquier lui avais dit elle est
là elle est là allez faites des enfants
c'est georges verts on va relancer la
natalité avec miss france malgré qu'elle
dit mais c'est comme s'ils avaient
appelé la france à ce jour là devant moi
by cc vitré sachez qu'ils accordent une
hausse bien la passion quand même parce
que ben el dib au public et chic et
c'est lui qui en plus une mini c'est
comme un président mais se branler alors
à sont des fanas de catherine rambert
qui est un peu jalouse elle et moi de
2,6 pas fan des miss france mais elle
est clairement là pour faire le buzz
c'est sûr pour préparer l'après ça c'est
sûr mais c'est pas à elle de dire ça
elle est sérieuse avait raison elle n'a
pas postulé au jamel comedy club elle a
postulé à miss france voilà entre les
miss france on représente un peu la
france alors juste quantité donne moi
j'ai rencontré hier geneviève de
fontenay c'était marrant d'avoir son
avis à l'effet fait plus l'émission
musée grévin
[Applaudissements]
qu'a fait pas très loin d'ici
d'abord jeunes edf ça la fait rire au
départ après été choqué le mail ans est
pas le rôle d'une mise parce que mr à
prendre mais très bien aménagé jason la
gardienne du temps a tendance à trop tôt
voilà alors attendez un mot de quelqu'un
qui n'aurait jamais pu être fait
clairement elle sent le fake moi je
trouve en tc faut on dirait qu'elle
cultive la différence pour être
différente et ça ça me dérange pas non
mais ça met de la phrase oui différentes
ça veut dire ça me dérange parce que
c'est pas naturel en fait on dirait
qu'elle fait exprès comme exprès pour
faire le bol est manquerait que j'ai
fait a noté daniel s'énerve parce que tu
n'es tu sais danser l'école je vous
parie mathieu une nuit avec moi j'avoue
parie que si elle était à nouveau comme
ça fait 20 ans qu'on râle parce que les
miss n'ont ils rien d'intéressant son
niaise l'ipad n'a fait que cette fille
elle a son accent elle a une
personnalité dont le premier modèle a
dit le jour de son élection c'est
sapristi vous en connaissez beaucoup de
filles qui aurait dit ça je suis désolée
elle est naturelle vous tente
normalement et honoraires aller si elle
était comme si on avait fini
excusez-moi arraché grâce à l'intérieur
à paris mais ne pouvait pas n'était pas
libre cpl avait peur
ses partisans j'avais 18 ans on va
mettre les ist tenir